orbiting the Earth at 17 500 miles per
hour
[Music]
I'm sorry the International Space
Station because there's two now the
international one used by the U.S Russia
Europe Canada Japan and others and
China's Tian gong which became fully
operational at the end of 2022 they plan
to use it for at least the next 10 to 15
years meanwhile the International Space
Station is set to be retired before that
International Space Station is going
down tiny Space Station's going up I
won't say it's a Changing of the Guard
but does indicate that things are
changing the the the people who are up
in space are changing the evolution of
use of space is changing Chinese and U.S
astronauts aren't allowed on their
opposing space stations they are
effectively banned from directly working
together because of one small section in
a 2011 law here's why the U.S and China
don't work together in space and why
that law is now a big debate in the
space community
leading up to the amendment there was a
lot of tension between the U.S and China
there were numerous cyber attacks
including on members of Congress on
these computers was information about
all the case work I've done on behalf of
political dissonance and human rights
activists around the world in 2007 China
completed a ballistic missile test
creating a tremendous amount of debris
when it destroyed a weather satellite
debris the International Space Station
still has to maneuver around
in new stories at the time the concern
wasn't immediately the station but the
showing of China's military might space
is a key National Security enabler
Victoria Sampson works for an
organization that promotes global
cooperation in space her career has
focused on that intersection between
space and the military there's kind of a
natural correlation between a ballistic
missile program and a satellite launch
program that was only the Third Country
to do that sort of thing the US and the
Soviet Union had done them during the
Cold War but there hadn't been one
officially for decades at that point I
think that was really kind of a reminder
that there are new actors in space and
new interests and so the United States
needs to think about how it wants to
deal the space then in 2010 the head of
NASA went to China to begin talks of
collaborating together possibly even on
the International Space Station as he
described it in 2021 before I went met
with Congressman wolf because he was the
chairman of the the House Appropriations
Committee responsible for asset funding
and he asked me not to go in fact he
told me not to go he's talking about
that congressman Frank Wolf who was
passionate about investigating and
punishing China's human rights abuses
and felt that even normalizing trade
with China in the 90s was fundamentally
immoral and this Congress is ready to
ratify a fundamentally immoral policy a
policy that has no morality behind it in
2011 he added a clause to that NASA
funding bill that says the space agency
can't participate collaborate or
coordinate bilaterally in any way with
China or any chinese-owned companies
unless it's approved by Congress
it's called The Wolf Amendment it's not
a total ban but it's created what many
call speed bumps which functionally
serve to ban collaboration the wolf
Amendment does not prevent the United
States from doing things with China on
Space issues but it does send a message
that the United States is leery about
working with China on Space issues the
U.S has long use space as kind of a soft
power the U.S Russia relationship was a
key example of that working together on
compatible docking systems despite the
Cold War and then of course the space
station the International Space Station
has been a very effective tool for
diphonic outreach but you know the
United States wasn't reaching out to
other countries how the goodness of Phil
and heart it felt that there were
benefits that the program could get from
the various Partners the Russians had
you know experience under the Soviet
Union of having their own space stations
they will bring that tactical expertise
China originally wasn't part of the
International Space Station because they
just didn't have the technical knowledge
at the time this is the total amount of
launches conducted by the U.S and Russia
and here's China in 2011 while their
space program had improved they were
still far behind
or as Congressman wolf said at the time
he didn't want to give China the
opportunity to take advantage of our
technology and we have nothing to gain
from dealing with them but a decade
later things have changed
China has been quickly stepping up how
often it launches and the future plans
of both countries will be in the same
place the Moon
NASA says they plan to have a crude
mission in 2025 look to establish a
longer-term presence there and in the
years ahead establish another
multinational space station the lunar
Gateway that will orbit the Moon China
says they also plan to have a camp on
the same part of the Moon by 2028 but if
these two base camps want to coordinate
or collaborate they need to go to
Congress 30 days in advance particularly
when you're looking at such a hostile
environment such as the Moon it seems
foolish to needlessly complicate
relationships and create a hostile
working environment with one of the only
other countries that perhaps could help
out human beings on the moon just
because you have hostile relationships
on the ground that's why there's a
debate in the space Community about
whether this law should exist in its
current form if you look at what was
congressman Frank Wolf's purpose which
was to try to isolate the Chinese into
uh more closely abiding with our our
Norms in human in human rights uh it did
not accomplish its purpose at all
um if we're looking at uh slowing their
program or keeping them from developing
a space program it did not do that at
all unfortunately what it has done is
caused us to now be on the outside
looking again as China and presses
forward with their 50-year space program
and doing things that some people say
they're moving at an incredible Pace
Congressman wolf who is now retired told
the Wall Street Journal in a statement
that if a planned collaboration doesn't
meet the amendment's basic criteria NASA
has no business doing it and referred to
China's continuing human rights abuses I
think the wolf amendment is going to be
around for a while
um partially because no one wants to
spend the political Capital to get rid
of it partially because I think the
pendulum is really swung in terms of
concerns about China as a rival or
threat they could go to the South Pole
of the Moon where the resources are
and they could land and they'd say this
is our exclusive territory you stay out
and uh
we're not going to let that happen
the wolf amendment has been kept in each
NASA funding bill since its creation but
as the US and China both move closer to
the moon the space communities debate
over collaboration may become a
congressional one
foreign